[Music]
thanks for everyone for attendance going
to talk a little bit about some cover
crops today and some things that we've
incorporated up on our operation in
north central Kansas and a lot of this
started really from back in my extension
days after out there would go to a lot
of different field days see a lot of
presentations on the benefits of cover
crops and solve them working in people's
rotations for grazing for hanging or
just for increasing soil fertility
getting more use out of the out of the
soil and the moisture especially here in
eastern Kansas but I was seeing very
little data if any on the economic
returns that was coming from these cover
crops because I was seeing a lot of
costs that we're incurring from that and
so a couple years ago applied for a ser
producer grant to kind of look at some
different treatments of applications for
cover crops there so chose a location on
the farm and this is on part of my dad's
land through that that you really had
good access obviously to water and pens
for grazing because for the grazing
component they're just a little bit
about the field that I chose it's a
continuous we're all kind of farm wide
we were in between 15 that some of our
land has been a continuous no-till for
20 disobey I just ending the 22nd year
through there this particular field had
been in continuous no-till for 15 years
I had been in had seen alfalfa and then
our typical corn soybeans and wheat
dryland rotation there some slight
variation in the field there so we chose
this was this is a 61 acre plot through
there and I'd just kind of divided it in
thirds a plot for that we were gonna
graze a plot for hanging and then just
apart for you know leaving on the ground
to look at the look at the other piece
there so ended up with to differ
mixes of cover crop seeds they're very
very fortunate to have a neighbor good
friend and that by the name of Dale
Strickler how works for star seeds he's
just down the road from me so I you know
I went to him and said hey what should I
plant here and he gave me all these
options and I was like Dale just tell me
what to plant and he's a he knows what
he's doing when it comes to this stuff
so I I I just went with his thing so
over the parts for living alone and
grazing we went with the mix of 30
pounds of oats 20 pounds of Springfield
piece 3 pounds of radishes couple pounds
of turnips and a pound of a forage
sorghum through that something we kind
of threw in at the end and then for the
hade for the hade portion which this
makes perfect sense we kept everything
the same except we eliminated the radish
and the turnips from there because as
Dale had experience you know when you're
going through if you're swapping your
swath or will kick up one of them turn
issues or radishes or the baler could
into the win row and if that gets into
the Bale that is not good it's gonna rot
and probably ruin a good chunk of the
bale so in that in that third I did not
have the radishes and the turnips so we
planted it into wheat stubble on August
the 6th was kind of a that would have
been about three weeks after harvest
that year and then in non-typical north
central Kansas weather you know you
gotta love this you plant something on
August 6 thinking this is crazy what's
gonna grow on August the 6th and within
2 weeks we got 8 inches of rain very not
typical for north central Kansas and so
you want to talk about optimal rainfall
through there and you see that samples
taken i pulled samples on october 14th
and this was in this this was in the
this was an average of the forage in non
forage 18.1 five tons per acre of wet
weight through that so we produced a lot
of forage and a very
amount of time which is which is just
perfect so as you'll see a lot of my
results here I have a few disclaimers in
that because actually this past year
would have worked Fri just as well from
that but maybe can't think of that as
being your typical results so you're
gonna plant something like this and
Kansas in mid-august and get 18 tons of
product on acre so let's look at some of
our costs here now you see what I have
the establishment costs were just the
leaving the loan so this is just what it
costs to put the crop in the ground I
had 15 dollars and 59 cents in
additional chemical application so I did
an extra we did an extra roundup burn
down on the wheat stubble there so
that's the cost of the chemical and
application and then as you noticed you
know from that seed mix if you know much
about it you're talking about a lot of
different sizes of seeds there a lot of
different mix and I just felt the most
comfortable our coop up there Aurora
co-op has a really good custom drilling
program with the right equipment so I
thought that was a good investment so I
went ahead and spent the 17 almost 17
and a half bucks an acre to have it
custom drilled and then the seed was
close to 40 bucks an acre 33 dollars and
79 cents for the mix that had the
turnips and the radish is there you know
you see the results see the size of my
hand
there was tillage radish is much larger
than that out there but that what I
would call as a pretty typical tillage
radish sizes you know more than half of
the the width of my hand and went down a
substantial amount into the ground a
couple of the guys that work for my dad
swore as they were going out moving the
the fences around in that they're like
there's turnips besides volleyballs out
there and I said why don't you bring one
back I want to see one of these
volleyball sized turnips and one of
those never came to fruition in reality
but we did have quite a few turnips
larger than softballs
through that so on the head portion
again so we planted this August the 6th
October the 14th we hate it so this was
roughly a 20 1 acre plot got 38 bales
just we just put it in round bales
averaging 1,750 pounds each had it
tested crude protein value right 16
percent relative feed value 150 so I'd
put this right at medium grade alfalfa
there you see pretty pretty
healthy-looking wind rose through there
no we raked them in that knot we did hit
hit it right with getting it put up
right before there was too much rain I
don't know how much you can see from
there we had it froze a lot earlier than
it did this year then you see at that
point forage sorghum had already you
know it had gotten burned pretty good by
the frost at that point through that and
so what did that what does that yield
right at one point five nine tons per
acre is what that came out and so at the
time of the that this that this was
taken the going price for that grade 150
relative feed value alfalfa was right at
90 bucks per ton in our area so I assume
if you were looking at this as an income
per ton type of thing that feeds worth
$90 a ton sitting there in that shed and
then I had seventy three dollars and
forty cents worth of expenses in that
for net income per ton 1666 and so what
does that do kind of the sensitivity a
price is there so again you know we're
right here right here in this level from
there and if you're just comparing this
and taking out any of the soil quality
benefits and just looking at paying for
the price of your seed the planning and
putting the hay up seeing if you could
see them where that would come from you
can afford at that price about seventy
three dollars per ton is what how far
down the hay price could be now
unfortunately where we at today up in
our area we're here in this 55 maybe
sixty dollars per ton REE
as what as what hey would be I think
you'd probably be pretty happy if
someone came and offered you $60 a ton
for hey right now so maybe you're in 50
range and so at this price you know is
just kind of take note that you know
even given the high yields and some of
this through that you kind of the bottom
line would be you can find some cheaper
hey then then what we produced on the
field but that's not and so you need to
weigh in if you're thinking about this
for your own operation if that thirty
dollars of quote-unquote cost per ton is
is really worth as is if you're getting
enough benefits from the cover crops
from from that so and you'll see kind of
some slides some subsequent things that
have happened on that form that I think
are worth quite quite a good amount and
so just kind of the same thing here's
where I was at one point five nine tons
per acre and then you could substantiate
about a twenty percent decrease in yield
to still kind of breakeven given those
given those prices that were that were
there through that the grazing portion
we turned out the first package of
steers 58 head they're weighed 858 for
26 days and just the way with my family
we have a background in feedlot up there
and it just kind of how it worked for
the timing of our ranch we ended up
putting two sets of a cattle two on this
grazing system just the way things were
time so the first package was on there
for 26 days the second package was on
there for 60 days so 86 days of grazing
terminated the grazing on January the
17th is when those the last day they
were out there and then we do supplement
you know the the steers were brought
into it pen that's where the water was
and everything and they were
supplemented with seven pounds of corn
gluten pellets per day every day
regardless
forage during wet conditions we had some
wet days there and you know that is a a
working crop field out there that we
didn't there was several times I think
about eleven days throughout this time
period that we did not turn the cattle
out and so we provided forage as a
supplement feed during that time and
then something I never even thought of
when I was designing this grant or
looking at this project is what did we
end up feeding for forage was the hay
that we put up in the shed there you
know I just it's kind of simple now when
you think about it like of course you
would do that but it was just one of
those steps I never quite closed that
loop until you know we were thinking
this through and hey we can't turn the
cattle out well there is a shed full of
hay that's that same crop that's up
there so it really it worked out at just
that really worked out neat to have that
that portion of the of the hade part
through that so so that's the piece
there so you look at 58 head total over
86 days of grazing and the average daily
gain on these cattle 2.13 pounds per day
so so it was really there and if we just
kind of normalize that put it on over
across the 58 head there was pounds of
gain per head right over a little over
183 pounds of gain we got during this 86
day time period there and so the total
cost this doesn't obviously include the
cost of livestock but the cost of the
you know the cover crops valuing the
forage that we did there the the pellets
we even calculated some some yardage
costs and then even some I calculated
what the labor was for to to put up the
electric fence and to move it I costed
everything out on that had about a cost
per head for this 86 days right under
124 bucks a head put that down to how
many pounds we gained cost per pound of
gain 68 cents per pound there and that
stood up against any any package of
cattle we had
year you know as being the most
economical way to put gain on cattle now
you'll notice I've just I chose just for
a lot of reasons there's a lot of things
if you remember what cattle prices were
a year ago they were they're in a lot
better situation than then now a lot of
things have changed in since so just for
as a fairness and to just go out there
I've just decided to kind of report from
this cost per pounds of gain because you
can imagine what we were what we were
selling cattle for then this this was a
pretty profitable type of operation
through that and so but I really just
chose to focus on this is the bottom
line is a pretty efficient way to put
that and again I want to put some
caution out there we had really optimal
rainfall and high cattle prices that
year because this worked very well was a
great was a great Innes pretty large
scale experiment and report and I've
enjoyed learning a lot and reporting it
and enjoyed continuing this you know
without the help of the grant on other
parts of our operation but but there's
always just some caution I want to lay
out there with that and then some
lessons learned so the following May
received nine inches of rain I an about
the course of four hours on that field
and that was it was something else a lot
of people a lot of people lost a lot of
ground there was some significant gully
erosion in portions of that field but
compared to you saw you know how good of
a how good so it's tough to see this
picture I'm sorry
but this is a portion that's hade so
it's pretty far down this is after the
grazing had done and the steers that had
good run of it and it was still pretty
still had quite a bit of growth there
there was so much there holding the soil
there it's pretty tough for - it's
pretty hard to imagine what would have
happened without that and then there's
surprisingly little regrowth after the
hang you know we hade that stuff in
October and you know it's waft it we
didn't
soif it down as low as you would like
alfalfa or that regular we we we've had
the header of the swather up a bit but I
figured there'd be some regrowth in that
because it wasn't like in the dead of
winter yet you know obviously
mid-october so is interesting they're
surprising little regrowth and very very
little to know that's always the
thousand dollar question people with
cover crops hey can you attribute any
you know decline increase in the
following year's crops we planted corn
on that next year and there was no there
was no impact on corn yield but then
again had did have adequate rainfall and
I will say what was interesting about
this is it's my farm that's across the
road from this tract of land and we were
always on the same rotation schedule of
that and then obvious on my farm across
the road when the combine left my farm
there was not a single bit of activity
on that farm until the following April
when the corn planter went in and you
see all what we got off of the field
across the road because of this cover
crop activity which is really neat I
think use of the resources of course
this is a year especially where the
wonderful my technical term the pigweed
Palmer amaranth is very present up in
north central Kansas and people have
asked about that because you know it is
worth especially if you're gonna follow
a cover crop after wheat you know
there's you have to watch your herbicide
program in your wheat because a lot of
the herbicides have a residual effect
will impact the the crops the next year
and so so you can't you have to use a
different herbicide program on that
wheat and I can't say that there were
any additional we had any additional
weed pressure or any last weed pressure
ice but you know I never went out and
did an official account that's just
pretty much a it's very unofficial serv
way there so so no impacts on on weeds
on either side of that but you know I do
know and I've heard of people look
at cover crop mix this is specifically
for weed suppression that just wasn't
really the goal of this and so that's
kind of I think that's the last slide I
had I had there like I said was this was
a great appreciated the opportunity for
the sare grant to kind of get our foot
in the door pay for a little bit of the
seeding costs and that and and we're
gonna continue to use them we had the
chance to have have a field day with
about 75 people on site the day we were
swapping the cover crop and then I've
just had the opportunity throughout my
travels to give this presentation
several times sit down with different
producer groups so it's been it's been a
neat learning experience and look
forward to looking somewhere
so the question was obviously we fed the
steer seven pounds of of corn gluten per
day and like any typical economist here
I will just give you a quick calculation
off of what that was so I would say
about fourteen cents fourteen cents -
that would be so that is that's not even
hardly 25% of that so that was given
corn gluten prices then which I'm sure I
know they've went down since there so
about 14 cents of that so that's just
part of our operation
I do give my grandfather and my dad some
grief I asked them if they're in the
catering business or in the cattle
feeding business because they do we do
tend to have some good forage some good
products like that in north central
Kansas but they're firm believer and
some supplemental feed and it's I know
it's not necessary but I I know where to
pick my battles and I'm not gonna win
that one
and the question was really quantifying
that value of the soil health and if I
could think of a way especially in a
one-year time frame like this to put on
some specific value I would have I would
have included it I love crunching
numbers and and and things like that
and so we're just kind of looking
long-term seeing what those you know we
grid and have you know you know utilize
precision AG and that and then have new
regular soil samples so I'm just keeping
track of these fields that have this
have additional have a cover crop
rotation worked into that to see to see
where we're at there but I think a lot
of the I think a lot of the values are
that you know especially and all systems
because even the cattle didn't the
cattle didn't capture all of those
turnips and radishes but that was you go
out there and the you know the next
spring and that's something like another
question I get at a pretty harsh winter
that year didn't have any problems with
regrowth that just all natural
winter killed everything everything I
did
but you up there in the spring when it
was heating up and it it smells pretty
strong out there it smells like cattle
taking off a turnips you ever had the
joy of experiencing that smell and
that's what it smelled with no cattle
out there and then let alone the the
wonderful nutrients the cattle were
spreading throughout there and there's
definitely there's definitely a value to
that and even if it would come up to you
know 10% of your overall nutritional or
you know soil soul requirements through
there it would be it would be pretty
significant but verdicts still out I
wish I could put a number that this is
how much fertilizer was saved through
that and it's just not that not that
simple of a I can't give you an answer I
feel comfortable enough on that so
[Music]